café Washington accuse donc maintenant
la Russie d'orchestrer une prochaine
entrée en guerre après des échanges de
tir d'artillerie entre force ukrainienne
et séparatiste pro russe dans le don de
base zelaski le président
ukrainien dénonce une provocation russe
Anthony blinken secrétaire d'État
américain dit maintenant à voir des
informations selon lesquelles la Russie
ciblera des groupes spécifiques
Ukrainiens on va écouter le président
américain Joe bye
ils l'ont retiré aucune troupe
premièrement ils ont amené des troupes
supplémentaires deuxièmement nous avons
des raisons de croire qu'ils sont
engagés dans une opération sous un faux
prétexte l'ordonnance une excuse pour y
aller toutes les informations nous
disent qu'ils sont prêts à entrer et à
attaquer l'Ukraine
est-ce que ça va arriver bientôt je
pense que ça va arriver dans les
prochains jours
allez-vous appeler Poutine je ne l'ai
pas appelé et je n'ai pas l'intention
d'appeler Poutine pour l'instant
le chef américain
je suis ici aujourd'hui non pas pour
déclencher une guerre mais pour en
éviter une rappelez-vous alors que la
Russie a plusieurs reprises tournées en
dérision nos avertissements et nos
alertes en mélodrame et en non sens ils
ont régulièrement amassé plus de 150000
soldats aux frontières ukrainiennes et
ont donc la capacité de mener un assaut
militaire massif